- It used to be that I would
say after World War II,
there was a very, very
strong impulse in America,
and across Europe to say,
"Look, Liberalism is all we,
it's all we need
people, you know,
private people will
make the decisions
about where the
guardrails should be,
what the constraints should be.
maybe that made sense to
a lot of people, then.
I think at this point, we've
reached the point where,
we're looking across
America and across Europe.
I mean, I think it's scary.
I think you can see
the chaos coming.
(low toned dramatic
synthesizer music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining
me today is one of the founders
of the National
Conservatism Conference,
president of the Herzl
Institute in Jerusalem
and author of the
brand new book,
"Conservatism: A
Rediscovery," Yoram Hazony.
Welcome back to
the RubiN Report.
- Hi Dave. Thanks
for having me back.
- It's good to see
you, my friend.
I sense by that background,
you are not in The Holy Land,
but perhaps a slightly less
holy land at the moment.
- (chuckles) I'm here in DC.
I actually wanted to
be with you in Florida,
but you guys didn't have
like room in the studio
for me or, something.
(Dave laughs)
So I'm in DC.
- It's a very, we've
been very busy.
I just got back from tour.
You're on the short list
of people I would've
been willing to have
here at the house.
But let's dive
right into the book,
because first off I've
got it in my hand.
This is a dense, powerful book,
full of a whole bunch of the
ideas that you've been talking
about for really
decades at this point.
But I wanna read just
the first paragraph off
the back flap here,
because I think you say
something very interesting
that I think is the thing that
sort of connects both of us.
You say Conservatism, as
we know, it has failed.
While Liberalism was
eroding the foundations
of our culture, the family,
the nation and religion,
Conservatives adopted
the very principles
that ensured their defeat.
Routinely confused with
Classical Liberalism,
Conservatism found
itself defenseless
before a ferocious
and relentless foe.
All right, now, you know,
I'm Mister Classical Liberal.
I think I helped
bring that phrase back
into the American lexicon.
But you also know that
I have found faults
within the Liberal lens.
We've discussed them before,
and we've discussed
them at NatCon actually,
just a couple months
back here in Florida.
So what brings you, well, first,
let me let you
define Conservatism,
and how it's different
than Classical Liberalism,
and then we'll go from there.
- Conservatism's
an Anglo-American
political tradition.
It goes back many centuries
long before Burke,
And it's a tradition that
puts the idea of transmission
and stability of the
nation at the center.
So a Conservative is always
going to be asking questions
like, "Have we upheld
the main principles,
traditions that
are holding our
people together?"
That can't go on forever.
There's always deterioration.
There's always
things that change.
And then a Conservative
is gonna be looking back
when something starts to
fall apart and saying,
"What can we restore?"
What can we go back
to that used to work
that we really need and
are sorry that we've lost?
- So I think a lot of
people are hearing that,
and that's pretty
clean and clear
that there were some hard
fought things of the past
that we should remember,
and perhaps bring back
into our daily lives.
Does Classical Liberalism not
grab a hold of all of that?
What's the problem there?
- Well, Classical
Liberalism is something that
is based on, like,
if you take a look at
the big thinkers of
the Enlightenment,
the rationalist thinkers
of the Enlightenment,
who originally designed this.
Liberalism, it's a
set of principles
that begin with every human
being is by nature free,
perfectly free and
perfectly equal.
And the purpose of government
is to give the
individual, to protect
the rights and
equalities that belong
to the individual by nature.
So the entire set of ideas that,
that are at the basis of
Liberalism they're basically,
you know, lots of
people said this,
they're basically, they are
a philosophy of freedom.
They're a way of thinking about,
how do we work it so that people
are maximally free
and unconstrained?"
And the problem
is, and this is...
This is something very
deep and very serious
that I really think we need
to be talking about much more
is that human beings do not
only need freedom by nature.
And if you think human
beings only need freedom,
then I think you've
got a mistaken
and misleading philosophy.
Human beings need
to be constrained.
They need to have
guardrails and guidelines.
They need to be encouraged
to do the things
that are needed in order
to keep their society,
their people, their
families, to keep it going.
And it used to be that I
would say after World War II,
there was a very, very
strong impulse in America,
and across Europe to say,
"Look, Liberalism is
all, it's all we need.
Private people will
make the decisions
about where the
guardrails should be,
what the constraints should be.
Maybe that made sense
to a lot of people then.
I think at this point, we've
reached the point where,
you know, we're looking across
America and across Europe.
I mean, I think it's scary.
I think you can see
the chaos coming.
The assumption of Liberalism
is let people argue
and be freely speak
and freely argue,
and they'll come to
the right decisions.
But I would say since 2020,
we're looking at an
America, that is,
is just, it's
tottering on having...
The woke neo-Marxist
ideology become kind of like
the public ideology
of the state.
And if you look sort of on the
edges of the political right,
like beyond Conservatism,
there's fast growing thinkers.
I mean that a lot of
the kids are reading who
are arguing for dictatorship.
They're just saying,
"Look, the whole idea
of the American
Constitution has failed,"
and they're looking
to dictatorship.
So I think it's becoming
really, really clear
that if we don't start
talking about conservation,
and transmission,
and restoration,
like a lot and focusing on it,
I think America is in danger
and I think it's in danger
of taking like the
Democratic countries with it.
- All right, so you're
hitting on a lot of the stuff
that obviously I focus on.
And I'm proud to say that
at the end of my first book,
"Don't Burn This Book," I
made an argument related
to God and belief
connecting some
of the classic Liberal
beliefs to that,
because I saw what
you're now talking about.
I sort of saw it on the horizon
that we could get to this point.
So first, do you think, is
that a flow flaw in Liberalism,
or is that a flaw
in human nature,
or is there even a
distinction there?
In that from say World
War II 'til about,
I don't know, maybe
five, 10 years ago,
the Liberal order
sort of worked.
Or I don't wanna put
words in your mouth.
In my estimation,
it sort of worked,
and then suddenly this
woke parasite got inside.
But would you say
that it roughly worked
for a certain amount of decades?
- Well, I think it's
been running down.
Look, I think, I think
2020 was a shocking,
was a shocking year in
terms of just institutions
all the way from
the New York Times
to Princeton University,
just being taken over.
I think it was a shocking year.
And I don't wanna say that,
there was obvious
that was gonna happen.
But I think as I write
in this new book,
I think the deterioration
has been really clear,
you know, almost a straight line
since the 1960s, even the 1940s.
But 1960s is when,
is when there's
this final decision
that the United States
is gonna ban God,
religious tradition,
prayer, Bible,
just ban it outright
more or less
from schools across the country.
And the theory behind it
was people said, "Look,
our country, we live
in a Christian country.
Overwhelming majority
of people are Christian.
We can be tolerant and
decent to other people,
but basically it's
a Christian country.
So we don't have to have
this stuff in the schools.
I think pretty much since then
the assumption that you could
just take God and scripture
out of the schools,
and it would continue to live,
on Sundays and in
people's homes.
I think that turned
out not to be true.
And what happened is first
in the name of equality,
and freedom from religion,
and everybody being
treated equal,
all religion was removed
from the schools,
God and scripture.
And after that then,
the idea of an
independent nation,
or of the family ended up kind
of being eliminated
from the schools.
And by this point, even
the idea of man and woman
being the basis of the
traditional family,
that's also now in
the name of equality,
and freedom from religion,
that's also been eliminated.
As I understand it,
it's been a one
way ratchet where
every 10 years, something else
that we will sorely
miss has been removed.
People just don't don't
know what to do with it.
I mean, I really think
an awful lot of people
in America and other
countries are saying,
"Look, this is just the
fall of the Roman Empire.
This is just the end."
You can't remove every
single, basic building block
of the way we built
society, throw it away,
open it to question,
and then think
that there's gonna be
anything but chaos.
That's pretty much what
looks like it's coming.
- Right. Chaos seems
to be at our doorstep.
So do you think
secular institutions
simply cannot work at all?
I mean, basically what
you're saying is there,
well, I guess everything is
gonna degrade over time, right?
- Everything degrades over time.
The question is, are
you helping it degrade,
or are you working
for a restoration?
Where you can see that
a mistake has been made,
so you can act to
try to stop it.
Look, Dave, I'm a religious
person, in the end.
In the end, I think,
we have to do what looks
right to us the best we can.
In the end, we're really
bad at seeing the future.
And what's gonna
happen is gonna,
God decides in the end,
what's gonna come of
all of our efforts.
But we have an obligation
to try to restore things,
to try to restore respect
for the American Constitution
and the Anglo-American
legal tradition.
We have to try to
restore respect
for the traditional family,
and for the Bible and for God.
That's up to us to try to
do, and maybe it'll work.
- So I think a certain amount
of people are watching this,
and what they may not
know is on the other side
of that very fine head
of hair, my friend
is a yamaka back there.
You are an Orthodox Jew,
you live in Jerusalem.
And yet, here you are
talking about Anglo beliefs,
a Christian America,
things like that.
I was on a panel
with you at NatCon,
where we were trying
to sort of work out,
it was the two of us
and Sohrab Ahmari,
who I've had on the show,
and Douglas Murray, who
I've had on many times.
Trying to sort of
whittle out where,
if you were to go back to some
of what you're calling for,
in a national
conservative country,
what happens to the minorities?
What happens to the
religious minorities?
What happens to people that
don't necessary prescribe
to all of the sort
of religious set
of views that you're
including here?
So what do we do with that?
- The book deals with
two different fronts.
One, is the question
you're asking me now,
which is about the public
life of the country.
And the other part
of the book deals
with our private lives.
Because people tend to think
these things are unrelated.
I think they're
deeply connected.
And so the book is really
an argument for people
to drop the idea that
you can just argue
for Conservative policy.
I think that you have to also
lead a Conservative life.
You have to come back
to a Conservative life,
and be a Conservative person.
So those two things.
Now, when I talk about
Conservative democracy,
I'm talking about a democracy.
I'm talking about the kind of
democracy that America was.
Sure, there's some
things from the past
that we should never go back to.
Slavery and persecution
of Blacks in America,
just as the most
obvious example.
I don't know any
Conservative that wants
to go back to that.
In fact, in my book
I make the argument
that that was a deviation from
the Anglo-American tradition
which is for a very long time
was anti-slavery before
there were slaves in America.
But since I'm arguing for
democracy I'm still talking
about the political
framework where
this should not be
imposed on anybody.
We're talking about those states
that still have a
Christian majority.
Or let's say maybe
there's Orthodox Jews who
would support this kind
of thing, or others.
So those states, those
regions, those places
where there's still a desire
to lead a Democratic life.
But where the public
philosophy, let's say,
is not neo-Marxism.
The public philosophy is going
to be based on a
Biblical vision,
on a Christian
and Jewish vision.
And my assumption is that
anybody who actually wants
to do this, I'm not
just assuming it,
I mean this is what I...
I talk to Catholics, and
Protestants and Jews.
I talk to them and try
to understand people
from all over the
country, what's possible?
And I believe that there is a,
the people looking
at sort of the cliff
that America's just
hurtling towards
this cliff and about to go over.
I think an awful lot of
people, Protestants, Catholics,
and Jews, and others
would be willing
to negotiate some
kind of a return of,
let's say the basic,
Christian moral vision.
To be like the public
background against
which things are
operate, in some places.
I mean, in some
states in the US.
And I think the
Conservative way to do this
is not to have the
Supreme Court dictate this
to people who don't want it.
The Conservative way to do
it is to experiment with it
in those places that want it,
so that we can see what
does this add up to?
Instead of like saying,
"Well, Christians
were always terrible
throughout their history."
Let's see what the Christian,
which I don't
believe, by the way.
But instead of that
argument in the air,
we should do an
experiment, let's see.
Let's see what does a, what
do the Christians in America,
when they get to be
the public culture
in a few states,
what do they do?
If it's better, and I'm
guessing it's gonna be better,
if it's better, so people
will want to move there,
and other states will adopt it.
And if it's as terrible as
everybody's always saying
to let the Christians
where they're a majority
to let them have the
public, if it's so awful.
So we'll see that it's
awful, and we'll say,
"Okay, we tried that,
that didn't work.
Let's do something else."
- So do you see something
like what's going
on here in Florida, where
I think we're defending
almost everything
you're talking about,
but not from the
religious perspective.
In that the governor is
up there talking about
this stuff from a
religious perspective.
However, he's doing
a lot of the work
that I think you're calling for.
- Yup.
- He is acknowledging
differences biological
between boys and
girls, and getting rid
of critical race theory
out of the schools.
And he's fighting
against against
a constantly overreaching
federal government,
all those things.
I think I sense that
you still think that
that may not be enough
for the experiment
as you wanted, is that right?
- No, I don't think it's enough.
The basic problem is
that for many years
most Liberal scholars
and professors who talked
about this kind of
things, theorists,
they talked about Liberalism
as a neutral state.
Like a state that
wouldn't actually have
any kind of moral vision.
It would just be neutral
and let everybody
do what they want.
This book argues, I mean, I'm
certainly not the only one,
but I'm arguing, there is no
such thing as a neutral state.
You can try it,
but it continues to
be mostly Christian
values up until the moment
that it just falls apart,
and you suddenly realize
that it's anti-Christian.
And I think that's
what's happening,
that's what's
happening in America,
and in Britain, and
in other places, too.
Is that there is a
public philosophy.
But that public philosophy
is progressive,
woke, neo-Marxism.
I know that there are a
lot of good Liberals who,
they want to hold
on to the idea of,
well, let's just go
back to a neutral state.
I think they just
don't understand that
that's collapsed, and it
hasn't collapsed by accident.
It's collapsed
because of the fact
that when you're saying,
"No, the state is neutral,
we don't have to defend any
particular set of values."
When you say that,
then you just open
the door for the
Marxists to take over.
The only way you can fight
a serious, public religion,
or public philosophy, is with
another public philosophy.
- So I get it, I get
you on the Liberal part.
I talk about Bill
Maher all the time,
where the five remaining
sane Liberals in America,
they just are sort of in
this slow motion paralysis.
And two years later they get it.
They repeat what
a bunch of us say,
but they keep voting
for the wrong people.
So I'm with you on that.
But what would you
say is not enough,
for say what Ron DeSantis
is doing in Florida?
I mean, I can telling you from
living her for four months,
I'm living in a free state
that feels strong and defended.
And it is starkly
different than California,
which made all of
the wrong decisions
and went that route.
- I think the number one thing
is that sending kids
to schools where
five days a week,
or whatever it is,
they spend their time
in an environment
that is strict of
any reference to God,
or to the Bible is the basis
of Western civilization.
The Bible is the
fundamental text
on which Western
tradition was built.
I think that that doesn't work.
I try to go into the
psychology of all of this,
and how it actually works.
'Cause I think people
don't understand this.
If you want anything,
you know, young people
are always saying, "What
do you mean Conservative?
Conservatives don't
conserve anything."
Right, you've heard that.
People say that all the time.
What have Conservatives
succeeded in conserving
in the last 50 years?
And I think we have to take
that argument seriously.
There's a constant role
in cultural revolution.
And the reason for
the constant role
in cultural revolution,
which just rips up one
thing after another,
is because of the fact
that nobody's focused
on how does the transmission,
the conservation of
ideas, actually work?
And for the way
it actually works,
is that if you're a kid, and
you see that people give,
the people around you
give honor to something,
let's say the Bible.
They give honor to
it. What do I mean?
They say, "Look, this
is really important."
Now, I'm not talking
about them saying,
you have to believe this, or
if you don't believe this,
then you're a terrible person.
I'm talking about
something much more basic.
That if you're in an
environment where people
are giving honor, they say,
"Look, this constitution is,
the best that there's
been in the world.
And this scripture is
the best moral framework
for leading your life
that there's ever been."
When you hear that from
people you respect,
your mind opens up.
Everybody's always saying,
"Oh, your mind closes."
That's not my experience.
If people are saying, "Look,
this is just really important.
You should take a look at it,"
your mind opens up to learning.
And right now, in America
and lots of other places,
I mean this is true
for most of you,
this is true for most
Democratic countries.
The kids, the adults,
people's brains
are snapped shut like a trap.
Somebody starts
talking about Bible,
and they think, "Oh,
that's that primitive,
dark ages stuff
that we got rid of."
People are scared
of it, people are...
They just think
it's like you must
be some kind of idiot for
talking about this stuff.
And as long as the
Bible continues
to be under this
shadow, instead of being
this spectacular
document that created
the world we live in.
Instead of that, people
just keep saying,
"Oh, that's the dark ages."
So the disintegration of
what used to be America,
it's inevitable, you pulled
all of the vacuum tubes
out of the back
of the television.
I mean, that's like
I'm dating myself.
You pulled all the,
sorry about that.
- The HDMI wire?
- You pulled, right,
you pulled all the...
- The red and the yellow.
- Yeah, you know, the little
square things in the back.
You pulled them out and
you stepped on them.
You get what I'm saying?
And then you're surprised
the thing stops working.
So you got to get
it working again.
And to get it working again,
we need to be able to
give honor to those things
that allowed our
ancestors to create
a free, and constrained,
and decent society.
- So I hate to keep bringing
this back to Florida,
but you know that it's really
just on my mind these days.
And I'm so impressed with
what's going on here.
I think I sense what
you're saying is basically,
Florida's doing a
pretty darn good job.
You'd like to see
the reinstitution
of some religious
teaching in school.
You do make a carve
out for, let's say,
the non-believers, or people
of minority religions,
et cetera, et cetera,
but is that it?
Is that basically the only thing
that you think is going wrong?
'Cause to me, what's
happening here right now
at a secular level,
and I don't even think it's
purely at a secular level.
DeSantis doesn't talk
about religion a lot,
as far as I know, but he's
talking about reality.
And I think his reality
is based in something.
- Yeah, I'm look, I
don't want to, look,
I like DeSantis and I
like what he's doing.
But I think that
what's sort of missing
from the conversation
is a longer view.
- That's what I'm asking, yeah.
- Because everything
that's going on right now,
is mostly reactive.
Its reacting
against the excesses
of woke neo-Marxism.
And God bless him for doing
that, and the legislature.
And Chris Rufo, and
all the people who
are working at the grassroots
level, God bless them.
They really are trying
to save their country,
and I hope they succeed.
But we're at the very,
very beginning of this.
And what's actually
gonna happen is,
as Christian activists
like Rufo start
to get, just look beyond, just
reacting, and trying to...
Try to get the worst of the
stuff out of the schools,
you're gonna find out
that that's not enough
to transmit anything,
it's just not.
The schools without the woke
stuff from 15 years ago,
that's how we got here.
- Mm-hm.
- In other words,
the way that we got
to the mess that we're in now,
is that 15 and 20 years ago,
everything was run by Liberals.
And so I'm just trying to look
just a little bit
beyond the horizon.
No, I don't think it's
just a matter of education,
but I don't want
to speak for, look,
I think there's gonna be a
number of different states
and countries and they're
gonna try different things.
So some of those
things could be,
they could be Sabbath laws.
You know, some people might
want try having Sabbath laws.
It could be legislation
about what the family is,
it could be legislation
about abortion.
I mean, it could be
all sorts of things,
and I think a smart
governor, or leader,
what he would do
is he would say,
"Look, I don't want to take
the most controversial stuff
and try to force it on people."
That's just not
smart leadership.
I think that in every
state what'll happen
is Conservative
leadership will say,
what are the kinds of
things that we have
a majority, and they
can get behind this,
and they think that
this could make sense.
And they'll try
different things,
they'll see what can work,
and they'll do experiments.
So would your
argument, let's say
they do this in Alabama.
Would your argument then be,
well, you're in the
free United States,
then if you don't like
what's going on there,
whether it's Sabbath laws,
or whether it's related
to the traditional family,
and I do want to obviously
discuss a little more on that.
- Right.
- That you should just get up
and get going to California?
- Yeah, why not?
I mean look, if you
want to know why
there are borders.
Like why do we divide the
world up into countries,
and states, and
municipalities with borders?
The reason we do that
is because we assume,
if we're not totally insane,
then we assume that local
people close to the ground,
that they know what
their people can want,
and what they can put up with,
and what's best for them.
Now, that's obviously
not always true,
but it's more likely to be
true than some distant emperor
who's dictating
everything to everybody.
- This is very much
what your first book was
by the way, virtual nationalism.
- Right, right.
So that's the reason
we have borders.
Now, America was founded
as a Federal Republic.
That Federalism has,
basically since World War II,
it's been progressively ruined.
The national Supreme
Court takes away the right
of the different
states to do any kind
of experimentation on major
things, on major issues.
So part of the program
has to be Federalism.
It has to be giving
power back to people
to try things at
the local level.
Look, nobody ever
thinks that everything
that their government
is doing is the way
that they would do it.
Government is always
somebody else,
and not only that, but it's
always like a combination,
even if you're in government.
It's a compromise, and it's
a combination of things.
But the bottom line answer is,
instead of having the
national government impose,
one system on
everybody, let's go back
to the old Federalism.
And let some of these issues,
which are just
tearing America apart,
Let some of them be worked on
at the state level,
at the local level.
There's some chance that people
will hate each other less,
if they can say, "You know,
I didn't like it in Alabama,
so I moved to Massachusetts."
- Look, I can tell you as
someone that left California,
I don't really care that much
about California anymore.
That's not to say that
there aren't good people
that live there. Of
course there are.
I still have a couple friends
that haven't made the move yet.
California's a beautiful place.
But unfortunately the
political leadership
has chosen its direction.
And I just don't want that much
to do with it at this point.
And they shouldn't have
that much to do with me
as a citizen of the
free state of Florida.
So before we get into some of
the granular stuff on that,
has there ever been a time
in the world where a country
or a group of
people got so close
to the precipice, got
so close to that chasm,
that bottomless pit
and then turned back?
Or is it just entropy
that almost has
to take us over at this point?
- No, look, there are forces
of entropy that's for sure.
Even successful
traditions, like,
I know two traditions
really well, pretty well.
I know the Jewish tradition,
which is like 3,000 years old,
then I know this
Anglo-American tradition,
which is about 1,000 years old.
And what's really clear when
you study these long traditions
is that they run down
and then like a great,
like a restoration, there's like
a great man or a group
of great people who say,
"We see the precipice come
coming and we gotta restore it.
We gotta put it back
together again."
Just two obvious examples
in English history.
I mean, people know that there,
I think most people
probably know that
in the 1600s, 1640s, there was
a revolution, a
Republican revolution,
they killed the king.
They tried to have a Republic,
to revise the English
constitution that went
on for 15 years or something.
And it didn't work,
it didn't work.
They kept changing
the constitution.
They couldn't get
any kind of like,
cohesive solidity
back to their country.
And less than 20 years went by,
this guy, Matthew
Hale, who's like
a famous Conservative
thinker, Who's in my book,
he proposed let's
bring the king back.
And they brought
the king back, and
the settlement that
they ended up with
was a more moderate
constitutional monarchy
than what they had before.
An example that's
closer to Americans,
is the American
Constitution of 1787.
You know, people think of,
and I write about this at
some length in the new book,
people think of the
American constitution,
like they declared independence,
and they wrote the constitution,
there was like this miracle.
And then they just got it right.
But that's not what happened.
That's almost the
opposite of what happened.
What actually happened
is that in 1777,
the Americans tried to step
away from the Anglo tradition.
They wrote a constitution,
which is called the Articles
of the Confederation,
is what we call it today,
but it was a constitution.
And George Washington
and his forces tried
to fight a war against Britain
under that constitution.
It was a weak constitution.
Its purpose was Liberty.
Its purpose was to give as
much freedom as possible.
It didn't give the
anybody enough strength
to be able to do things like
raising an army, raising taxes,
being able to impose
a negotiated treaty
with another country
being able to impose on the
states, the terms of the treaty.
And after 11 years of this
chaos, I mean, where...
The American army was
moved to Georgetown
by people writing personal
checks as a donation,
because the country was so weak.
Washington came out
of this and he said,
"We need something like
the English government,
like the British government.
We need some kind of
strong central government
that protects freedom,
but it has the ability to
raise an army, raise taxes,
impose decisions
where necessary.
And that's how the American
constitution was born.
It's a restoration of the
constitutional tradition
of Anglo Americans.
That restoration was
because they thought,
we're going over the precipice.
If you just think
for one second,
like if they hadn't been
able to get private donations
to get the army to Yorktown,
I mean, they just could
have lost the war.
- It's interesting
because I've been saying
on my show for a
couple weeks now
that we've begun to
enter a post-woke world.
I do see a fight against
the woke movement,
the Marxism that
you're talking about.
And you're talking
about checks being sent
to keep the army going.
And, you know, Elon
Musk buying Twitter,
one federal judge
reversing the mask mandate,
individual people trying
for that restoration
is an interesting-
- Right.
- Is the most
American thing perhaps
that you could possibly do.
So let's link this to
something a little more recent.
So at the National
Conservatism Conference,
which was at the
end of October 2021,
you me, Sohrab Ahmar,
who I mentioned earlier,
and Douglas Murray were all on
a panel where we were trying
to do just what we've
been discussing here.
That we were trying
to piece together,
how do you take the
traditional sort
of religious
conservative perspective?
Where do you blend that with
the Classical
Liberal perspective?
How do you take a purely
secular Libertarian,
and the more, even the more
traditional Conservative?
how do you take all of this,
combine all of these people
with all of their difference,
make it into something
that's whole?
And what was
particularly interesting
about the conversation,
which we'll link to below,
so people can see it,
is that two of the
four panelists up
there happened to be gay.
Now that obviously,
is a minority
from a sexuality
perspective, let's say.
And we were really
trying to hash
through these issues in about
an hour and a half talk,
and nothing was
left on the table,
and we took questions
from everybody.
Where do you see that now?
And I don't know that,
I don't think we all got
to a full conclusion
on it, exactly.
I think Sohrab and
Douglas definitely
had some big
disagreements by the end.
But where do you fall on that?
- Look, I'm glad that
we did the experiment
And not only that, but
I'd like to keep trying
to do the experiment because I-
- Yeah.
- Because I think the reality is
that there's all these Liberal
refugees who are, you know,
they're moving to the right,
because they can see
something terrible
is happening on the left.
And Elon Musk. I don't
know if you saw him,
he tweeted this image.
- Oh, I saw it, we
played it on the show.
- Right. So I think a lot
of people feel like that.
He says, "Look, I've never
been anything but a Liberal,
but now I'm clearly
on the Right.
It's not that I've moved,
but the spectrum has moved.
It's being pulled like taffy
by the revolutionaries."
And so he sees himself now
as being part of the Right.
That's what's happening,
and what that means
is we have no choice.
There's going to have to
be some kind of alliance
between Conservative
and Liberals.
But that doesn't mean
that this is easy to do.
I don't think that particular
thing worked out so well.
Douglas came out of it,
and he felt like he needed
to write an essay saying,
"These conservatives, they're
too much, they're too far."
I don't know if you saw that.
- Yeah.
- Like two weeks after he-
- I've had Douglas on
my show since then,
and we discussed, yeah.
- Okay. So that was him.
And then Sohrab responded
to him by saying,
"I just don't see
how this can work."
And look, I'm not
terribly surprised, but...
- But that tension that
you're talking about,
I get it exists.
And that's why, I mean,
for years I've been saying,
if there is some sort of
new Conservative movement
on the horizon, I
still no matter what
at the end of the day,
will probably end up
on the more
Libertarian side of it,
or classically
Liberal side of it.
I think we're all trying to
do something that's tough.
And when you try to do
something that's tough,
or as Jordan Peterson would say,
when we were on
tour all the time,
that healthy tension
that perhaps we all want
between Liberalism
and Conservatism,
it's hard to balance
that all the time.
And maybe it can't, maybe
it just can't be done.
Maybe it can't be done
at a national level.
I think perhaps it could be
done at a personal level.
- I think you're a model
in what you just said.
That people can disagree,
and in the end of the day,
we ought to be able to just
go have scotch together.
And I do everything I can
to live like that myself.
In that, I'm following
the way that you talk
to people in the studio.
I really think that this,
that discussion should be
amicable between
people who are like...
We're not enemies,
we're friends who have
important disagreements.
- And by the way, removing
me from the equation.
If there's a
Conservative out there,
a religious
Conservative who thinks
that Douglas Murray is not
a good enough
Conservative for them,
then that's not my brand of
Conservatism, how about that?
- Well, no-
- To remove us from the
equation for a moment, you know?
- Well, Douglas is, look.
Douglas is a little
bit different,
because Douglas doesn't
claim to be a Conservative.
He doesn't claim to
be a Nationalist.
He comes to the conferences
and he says things like,
"You know, I probably agree
with 1/3 of the things
that are being stated here."
He deflates, you
know, he participates,
he's a great friend.
He participates fully,
but he doesn't,
he doesn't take a leadership
role among Conservatives
the way that you do.
And I'm not blaming
you for this.
I mean, I think everybody,
everybody has just
been really happy
to have somebody like
you taking leadership.
I think it's hit a bump
and I don't, you know,
I regret that, I'm
really sorry about that,
but I'm looking
forward to the scotch.
- (laughs) Listen, I
probably can't solve
all of the existential
issues for all of the people
that come at this from a
purely religious perspective.
And I think it's a great
challenge to blend a society
from a traditional and
religious perspective
that also has an awful lot
of secular people in it.
Although you happen to be
in the swamp right now,
you live in a country that's
only 70 plus years old
that has done a pretty good job,
but often an imperfect
job of blending
the secular and the traditional.
I suppose the best
thing we can do
is continue to have
these conversations.
- Right.
- Yoram, the book is
"Conservatism: A Rediscovery."
And we will do that whiskey
and/or tequila soon, my friend.
Good seeing you.
(book thuds)
- Okay. Thank you,
Dave, good to see you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.